classe un peu particulière pour ces
lycéens peut-être légèrement plus
attentifs que d'habitude
il écoute les derniers conseils avant de
monter sur scène
à moins d'une heure du spectacle la
pression monte qui a qui viennent
amusez-vous c'est important même si vous
pouvez vous ratés mais c'est pas grave
vous ferez mieux peut-être l'année
prochaine
il ya beaucoup de gens c'est la première
fois qu'il trouvait remonte sur scène
avec 950 personnes dans l'embarcadère
donc c'est pas toujours facile donc faut
toujours les dettes des effets détendre
un petit peu pour avoir le meilleur
spectacle aussi en tout 16 go vous
montez sur scène ce soir de la danse
vraiment tous les types de danse mais
aussi du chant et de la musique
[Musique]
côté scène la salle de l'embarcadère se
remplit doucement
ce soir les lycéens vont jouer à guichet
fermé devant 950 personnes est super on
vraiment un beau spectacle que je suis
vraiment au top
moi j'attends ça dans le dévouement
fondé beau spectacle
j'aime ça va je viens en même temps ça
ça profite aux restos du coeur
cette année le festival devrait
rapporter près de 25000 euros
restaurants du coeur de saône et loire
grâce à la billetterie et aux
partenaires du spectacle une somme
considérable
l'une de ses principales sources de
financement c'est une génération qui ne
lit pas la solidarité et c'est très
important de le savoir et se rendre
compte qu'ils sont capables de
s'investir on croit toujours que la
jeunesse est un petit peu indifférente
et c'est pas du tout le cas tant que les
remercier du fond du coeur
cette année c'est le groupe fil rouge
durant le spectacle
à quelques minutes de monter sur scène
derniers encouragements pour un concert
qui s'annonce très bien les gens sont
super contents d'être là on voit qu'ils
sont super enthousiastes ils sont
vraiment ils nous prennent pas afin ici
on fait des erreurs ils le prennent pas
mal enfin franchement c'est super
et c'est parti pour près de trois heures
de spectacle presque aussi long que le
vrai concert des des restos du
coeur avec qui les lycéens espère un
jour pouvoir chanter
ce